mais si market les membres de la ligue
des droits de l'homme bonjour à vous
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors c'est votre organisation
avec la quadrature du net qui a saisi le
conseil d'état sur cette question en
quoi l'utilisation des drones par la
préfecture de police de paris pose un
problème
alors tout d'abord la ligue des droits
de l'homme a constaté que l' usage de
ces drones ne répondait à aucune base
légale puisque c'est une initiative qui
a été prise par les services de police
sans sans saisine préalable de la cnil
sans saisine préalable du conseil d'état
pour avis comme ça plus déjà se produire
par auparavant le les pratiques
policières se développe aujourd'hui en
violation de plusieurs libertés et la
liberté d'aller et venir ici en plus la
liberté faire le droit au respect de la
vie privée et le droit au respect des
données personnelles et donc la ligue a
jugé utile avec les autres
la quadrature du net d'intervenir pour
rappeler à l'ordre entre guillemets la
préfecture de police qui a agit encore
une fois sans base légale et donc le
conseil d'état a pris acte de ce de ce
manque dans le dispositif policier et a
rajouté la préfecture de police a
enjoint la préfecture de police à
prendre les mesures qui s'imposent et
donc à suspendre l'usagé des drones
jusqu alors
mais pourtant les autorités assurent que
les drones ne savent qu'à filmer
uniquement les rassemblements de plus de
10 personnes et ne pas identifier les
visages
alors quelle que soit la finalité des
drones s'appelle être une finalité de
police judiciaire donc qui consisterait
par exemple à constater et à mettre fin
pour suivre et mettre fin à des
infractions
là en l'occurrence il s'agit de mettre
deux finalités de missions de police
administrative et les missions de police
administrative répondent en principe à
des textes qui doivent fixer un cadre
d'emplois dans tous les cas
ces missions doivent être prévus par une
base légale et répondre à des objectifs
à des finalités qui sont strictement
nécessaires et proportionnées
là en l'occurrence usage des drones a
été fait la pratique s'est développée
avant les textes qui les encadraient
donc c'est normal qu'il veut qu'elles
puissent être sanctionnés sera pas
forcément facile à d'encadrer les âges
des drones partout par exemple sur les
plages on sait que les drones sont
utilisés pour surveiller justement les
sites
ça risque d'être un petit peu compliqué
et c'est compliqué oubliez montre c'est
à dire qu' il s'agit avant tout d'une
pratique attentatoire aux libertés donc
c'est à l'état de prendre l'initiative
aussi de pouvoir réglementer cette
pratique comme il se doit donc saisir
les autorités indépendantes telles que
la cnil soumettre les textes à l'avis du
conseil d'état mais aussi peut-être en
revenir à un débat citoyen sur l'usagé
qu'on serait de faire de ce genre de
technologie est aujourd'hui la
technopolis c'est quelque chose qu'on
souhaite pour surveiller les blacks est
ce que la france peut fonctionner sans
caméra volante sur sur les plages c'est
une question qui relève à mon sens d'un
débat citoyen d'un débat parlementaire
est aujourd'hui le la pratique s'est
développée
encore une fois sans consultation
préalable mais mais vous n'êtes pas
contre une telle pratique les âges des
drones dans certaines situations
alors justement moi je suis assez
circonspect sur la position que prend le
conseil d'état dans la mesure où ils ne
considèrent pas comme illégitimes sur le
principe tout usage des drones à mon
sens c'est une question de choix de
société est ce qu'on a envie de pouvoir
être suivis par des caméras volante en
ne sachant pas exactement quel genre
d'image elles vont capter quel genre
d'image les livres ont enregistré quel
serait le délai de conservation ces
données etc
on peut partir du principe que le en
tant que tel c'est un dispositif
attentatoires aux libertés qui n'a pas
sa place dans une société démocratique
en tout état de cause ça appelle des
dégâts qui pour l'instant sont absents
donc la ligue des droits de l'homme
aujourd'hui a fait une avancée
spectaculaire en la matière puisqu'il
s'agit du premier procès pour faire
reconnaître ses pratiques et pour les
sanctionner
il y a de fortes chances que la
préfecture de police voire le ministère
prenne les mesures réglementaires pour
fonder pour une base légale sur ses
pratiques
en revanche on n'est pas du tout certain
que les mesures qui vont être prises
respecterait les libertés fondamentales
donc le cas échéant la ligue des droits
de l'homme prendra l'initiative une
nouvelle fois de poursuivre ce débat
dans l'enceinte judiciaire à défaut de
pouvoir avoir un débat parlementaire
pour l'instant merci beaucoup et c'est
marre car je rappelle que vous êtes
membre de la ligue des droits de l'homme